[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
doug deacon is the
radio color analyst for the browns he
spent 14 years as an offensive tackle
for the browns and uh
good to have doug back on the show doug
where do we stand here
trying to prepare for a playoff game
that this uh
city has waited 18 years for the
franchise is waited and
you're not gonna have a head coach or
one of your best offensive lineman
it's going to be a tough task and
obviously the steelers are getting some
guys back that did not play last week
so i think you know the key to the game
is going to be if the bronze can
establish their running game and win the
turnover battle
but also you're losing your an offensive
lineman who's been to the pro bowl a
couple times and you lose kevin
stefanski what one will be more
impactful
what's lost more impactful on sunday
well that's a toss-up because i think
you know when you you look
at baker and in the pocket uh you know
if you get
pressure in his face he's not the
tallest guy so he has a little bit of a
problem there
so betonia was stout at the line of
scrimmage but on the other hand kevin
stefanski has built
a great relationship with baker and you
know kind of brought
baker the that we thought we were going
to get out of uh
what we have and i you know i think
stefanski is underrated in what he's
done because
you know he's a great play caller and
he's been that calming voice i think for
baker mayfield with
considering what you had with freddie
kitchens last year
uh what do you think has been the
biggest difference in this team
this year as opposed to last year well i
think you know we uh
we used to have a coach dave adolf who
used to say do you want to be a
professional football player
or you want to be a professional that
plays football and i think kevin has
turned them into a bunch of
professionals that play football
what is it though that you're seeing
because it it it feels like there's
there's no drama there this year
well yeah the discipline the you know
the during the coronavirus there were
some people that
didn't adhere to uh what the rules were
so they were let go and uh
you know he's just very calmly you know
maintain the respect of the football
team and
uh you know freddie was a great guy i
would love to play for freddie but i
think sometimes freddie wanted the t
the guys to like him rather than respect
him
how big is this how important is this
for this city and this franchise that
after 18 years they're back in the
playoffs
oh i mean you could see the people
walking out of the stadium uh
last week with tears in their eyes i
mean it's something they've waited for
and there's a generation
of browns fans that have never seen the
browns in the playoffs and uh
you know it's been a tough pill to
swallow here
you made the playoffs i think what four
years four years yeah
yeah and and you you know you're going
against the steelers as well so
you know they're you don't need added
incentive but it's certainly there
considering what the steelers have done
to the browns
in particular in pittsburgh doug yeah i
mean uh when i played
well we went over 14 during my 14 years
over three rivers
but we had lost a year before and the
year after i retired so they can't blame
it all on me
we stayed in every hotel in pittsburgh
trying to change the caramel
well the problem is mean joe green was
still on the other side and you still
had chuck noll and terry brad
what what was it like to go against that
steel curtain
well you know it was uh one of those
regardless of how good they were you
know you always gave it your best shot
but
they you know up front you know
obviously you talked about joe and then
you had dwight and you had elsie and you
had ernie
but then behind them you had uh ham and
lambert
so and they were loaded i mean you throw
in mel blunt in the back end and donnie
shell
uh they were always physical football
games and there was one over there that
we should have won
unfortunately the referee blew a call
and
because of it we ended up losing single
toughest defensive player you played
against in your 14 years
uh i tell one a good couple
i think leroy selman joe klecko
coy bacon uh i i would say those guys uh
were you know the topic alvin bethe i
mean alvin i played twice a year for 13
years and uh
alvin uh was one of the greats
joe klecko's not in the hall of fame is
he doug no he deserves it
to make the pro bowl at three different
positions that's quite an accomplishment
much like you know we have clay matthews
who finally got into the final 15
and he played 19 years and uh played at
a high level for 19. so hopefully clay
gets in this year
well what happened is klecko got
overshadowed by gastineau
i think that you know he kind of sucked
all the attention uh
out of that team yeah but when we came
to the line of scrimmage the one guy we
were looking for was klecko because he
was a disruptive force
and it was what about six foot one or
two and he just pick you up and carry
you back to the uh
quarterback and you just kind of smile
and do his little pigeon toad walk
so how do you think this plays out on
sunday night doug
well i you know unfortunately it'd be
nice to
know who we're going to have and i think
you know we have some people in the
secondary
that didn't play last week that you know
really hurt us so hopefully we can get
denzel ward and uh
uh back and get kevin johnson which
would help us because
you know pittsburgh has kind of
struggled with the run and they've
become a past
first team and uh you need all the
defensive backs you can
so as the week goes on hopefully we'll
get denzel and kevin johnson back
good luck doug thank you we appreciate
you joining us as always
my pleasure that's uh doug deacon the
browns radio color analysts spent 14
years cleveland brown's offensive tackle